- I am honored to welcome her
to the show Elaine Welteroth.
(audience applauds)
- Drew Barrymore, is
this really happening?
I'm freaking out right now.
- Okay, so for a little backstory,
Elaine and I first met when
you were a beauty editor
at Teen Vogue.
- Yes.
And it was love at first sight for me.
- It was love at first sight for me too.
I was really new you at that
point in the beauty game.
I had been doing Cover Girl for years
as a co-creative director, but
you made me feel so welcomed.
When we're trying to do
something new it's intimidating
and the more support and
encouragement you have
to be reminded, go for it.
So that was something that
I always loved about you.
And then you became the
youngest editor in chief
in Conde Nast history
when you became the editor
in chief of Teen Vogue.
- Yeah, but I would actually like to say,
I'm very proud that I am no longer
the youngest editor in
chief in Conde Nast history.
There's actually an even
younger black woman,
who is now the editor
in chief of Teen Vogue,
after I departed that role.
She's killing it.
Her name is Lindsay Peoples Wagner.
I think it's so important
we celebrate firsts,
but I think it's so important to remember
the responsibility is to make sure
that you're never the last.
I think you feel that
pressure to make sure
that you do the job in a
way that keeps the door open
and widens that pipeline.
- So one of the last times I saw you
was at the Goop panel.
- Yes.
- In my mind I kept thinking,
what is Elaine's next act going to be?
And I had this divine intervention
and I was like, Elaine Welteroth
is literally going to be
this huge figure on
television, I just know it
because you have so much to offer.
- The fact that I'm sitting
on the Drew Barrymore Show right now
and that you're telling me this
just feels like a weird fever dream.
I'm like this can't be real.
- I'm just excited 'cause it
turns out I'm totally psychic.
I'm not kidding, I saw you, I was like,
she's gonna be a big talk show host.
And I just think it's the
perfect Elaine Welteroth fit.
- Well, I think it's the perfect
Drew Barrymore fit as well.
- I did not have a psychic
moment about myself.
I can't believe I'm here.
That one I wouldn't have guessed.
- I'm so beyond like
mind blown and honored
and it still doesn't even feel real
that I'm going to have
this opportunity as well
to just have conversations that matter,
to cultivate connection every single day
on national television.
I'm so over the moon and so
grateful to have that chance.
So it's exciting.
And I'm grateful that you,
I can't believe you're tellin'
me you had this vision.
- I not only had the vision,
but then you were doing some
fun stuff on Kelly and Ryan.
And I was like, this, this,
I'm not kidding, like I-
- I will tell you that day,
I remember seeing you at the
panel, it was the Goop panel
and Gwyneth Paltrow was up
there and had us all together.
It was such a scary time for me.
I had decided I was leaving Teen Vogue
and I had this big vision
in my mind about what I saw
but no one else did.
But I knew even at that point,
I thought like the worst
thing would be to feel stuck
in an identity that someone else
or that the world put me in,
like a box that I was put in.
- I was nervous to try and
get into a beauty game.
Nothing compared to my fear
about starting this job.
And it's changed me in ways
I could have never expected.
It's gonna be honestly I think,
one of the most important
years of my entire life
and listen, you're on
"The Talk", I'm on here.
We're a CBS Studios-owned
show, you're CBS.
We were sisters in beauty
and may we be sisters
in the talk show world,
because you are someone
that is one of my favorite,
you're just one of my favorite people.
So let's be sisters in talk shows.
- Let's be sisters, yes.
- I just wanna congratulate CBS
for making one of its smartest decisions.
- Thank you.
I just have no words.
You have made me for the first
time in my life, speechless.
So thank you.
- That takes a lot.
- And you made
a brown girl blush.
- I'm gonna get up and
give you a virtual hug.
- Yes, you know what? I have a hug.
Oh, oh, oh, my neck thingy.
- Are you stuck here?
That's okay, I'll come to you.
There we go.
- Wait, wait, oh my God.
- I can never line up.
Now I've got my arms crawling
out of the back of you.
- Wait Drew, we have to
do my quarantine hug.
Are you ready?
- I am ready, teach me Elaine.
- Okay, turn around.
Come closer to me, let's connect butts.
Okay, yes, and then we just go like this.
(audience laughs)
- I love it.
- This is my quarantine hug
for all the people I love
that I can't touch.
(upbeat music)